[Music]
hello everyone
in this part of the lecture we are going
to discuss an example
problem to illustrate the area stress
function approach
uh so this is the problem uh
in this situation you have addressed
numerous times during your undergraduate
studies
uh it's a it's a very simple beam
uh simply supported in a statically
determinate fashion
and it is subjected to a uniform load
okay uniform distributed load
now uh our objective here is to find out
the stress distribution in this beam
please note that the thickness of the
beam into the plane of the screen
is very very small okay and we are going
to consider that of
our unit width now
the question is how can we go from this
engineering structure a real engineering
structure
uh to a mathematical idealization which
will be suitable for the edit stress
function
so the first step as you had done in uh
in your undergraduate days would be to
draw the corresponding free body diagram
uh that will not involve the these
these explicit reactions rather these
will be
replaced by the reaction forces so let's
do that first okay something very
familiar to all of us
uh so
let me just copy this entire diagram
and just remove the
the reactions from the two ends
all right what i will do
instead is to
[Music]
replace the effect of those reactions
or the reaction supports uh
by this kind of sorry about that
let me use a different color maybe
so this is one reaction one reaction
force another reaction force
okay
all right and because there is a
perfectly symmetric situation uh
so you understand that these two
reaction forces are going to be equal
of course uh back in your undergraduate
days you had also considered a
horizontal component of the reaction
force here
but that will turn out to be zero uh so
i'm not going to
uh into those unnecessary details at
this stage
now uh for the purpose of proceeding
with the air stress function
uh what we'll do is to consider uh
uh not specifically this end
of the beam not this end rather i'll
consider
a portion starting from
a little bit to the right of this and a
little bit to the left of this
okay so what i mean to say is
that i will consider
a
a cut section like this which is very
very near to the end
okay
something like that and something like
that here
now when i do that these reaction forces
they disappear because i'm only going to
consider whatever is between these two
cut sections
okay so what will uh what is going to
happen
is that uh
i'm going to get a
so let me try to draw this
i'll get a rectangle which is slightly
smaller in length
compared to the previous rectangle same
height though
okay so something like that where you
note that i have tried to align this
edge
and this edge the left edge and the
right edge with these yellow colored cut
sections
okay everything else remains the same so
this entire loading that we had that
remains as it is
so that is very much present here
all right now you know that the way that
i have drawn this diagram
uh this is not really complete because
in the previous diagram
courts see the presence of these yellow
colored arrows uh
the whole uh free body diagram
was balanced okay uh now here we only
have this vertically acting downward
forces
but no vertically acting upward forces
so definitely
that must be compensated uh so these
kinds of downward acting forces must be
compensated by the
shear forces which are present on these
exposed
sections okay so uh what we'll do is
we'll we'll just depict that
to this half arrows please note that
this half
sorry about that uh
these kinds of half arrows please note
that these
uh half arrows uh
so this half arrow and this half arrow
although i have drawn it
uh in like like shear stress uh
components but these are actually forces
okay
so and then that will have tremendous
consequence
later on when you actually write down
the boundary conditions
so you also note
that uh
actually the sense of this is not quite
correct uh
so this let me correct this
okay so this is the direction of the
positive shear stress
uh consequently this is the direction of
the uh
of the positive uh shear force similarly
here
okay now this kind of a reverse kind of
a reverse looking kind of situation
arises because we have
the y axis downward
now uh with this diagram in hand
we can actually proceed to the use of
the edit stress function
now the first step that we need to do
[Music]
for the data stress function approach is
to write down the boundary conditions
okay so uh first
for the boundary conditions we need to
have some information about the geometry
and we can do that very quickly by by
noting that the height
here that's twice h
so so we say that this is
this height here is twice h
and uh we also say that
this entire length
that is twice a
i'm writing this in the form of twice a
and twice h because
uh because you note that this
this origin is at the center so we i
have a
length a on this side and a length a on
this side okay just to keep things
uh neat and clean similarly this origin
is at the center
of this height so uh above this height
okay uh in the direction uh above this
side
i have a i have h and below this height
below the center i have h now uh
when i have to write down the boundary
conditions i will i'll consider each of
these four
edges separately so first of all what i
do is
i write down at y equal to h
what do i have so
you please note that at y equal to h
the sigma yy okay the sigma yy
is actually pointed upward okay so if
you consider a little element here
the sigma yy will be pointed upward
which means
that this sigma yy is going to be equal
to
minus q naught
you also note i had not mentioned this
earlier
that q naught is a force but it is like
a
it's like a force
per unit length it is written like this
but you also note that the thickness
of this beam into the plane of the
screen is
uh is unity so this is like newton
per meter per one meter okay so in that
sense it is actually a newton
uh per meter square okay so there is no
conflict
with me writing sigma yy which is a unit
of pascal
as minus q naught okay and again i
emphasize
that this minus appears because as i
have written
or as i have drawn these forces these
are acting
in
in the downward direction and the sigma
yy
by the positive convention uh here would
be pointed upward
again at y is equal to h i have
for my sigma xy
sigma xy
is equal to 0 because i do not have
any shear stresses on this top
edge next
or or at y is equal to
so here i have already made one mistake
you please note that this
top edge there y is not h y is actually
minus h
because you see the y is pointed
downward so this is actually wrong
let me correct that the top edge the y
is equal to
minus h okay
so is an important correction and it is
the bottom
edge where this is y is equal to plus h
here sigma yy is equal to 0 because
on this bottom edge at y is equal to h
i do not have the presence of any normal
stresses
again sigma xy is equal to 0
so this positivity convention is very
important to write correctly
what about the the edges okay these
vertical edges
so there
let's consider x equal to a
at x equal to a what we are going to
have
is uh
so this is a bit involved
you have to write this down carefully
first of all let us talk about
this the normal stresses now
what we usually do for these vertical
edges is
uh not to write them in this kind of a
point-wise
fashion rather to write them in an
integrated fashion
so what we say is that the total normal
stress
is going to be or the total normal force
is going to be zero so sigma x x d y
integrated from minus h to h that is
going to be equal to zero so this is
basically
telling us that the axial force
along this x direction that is equal to
0
similarly
we must have the bending moment that
must be equal to
0 so y sigma xx
dy that must be equal to 0
okay
so this is at x equal to a what about
the sigma xy
so uh we have already mentioned this
that this yellow color thing
this is the uh
so this is the shear force
and you understand that because of the
symmetry of the situation
this shear force and this shear force
they must be of the same magnitude
okay so although by the positivity
convention i have drawn it like this
downward pointing but actually this
needs to be
pointed upward and this needs to have
a magnitude equal to
q naught times a okay because
this is q naught here uniformly
distributed
over a length twice a so half of that
load
given by q naught a goes here or is
supported on this
uh this side and the other half q naught
a is supported on this side
okay so or since your reaction forces
here would be
q naught a each these yellow colored
uh arrows would be q naught a each so
also these shear forces
uh that we have depicted in this diagram
this must be of the magnitude q naught
a so sigma x y
uh
d y integration
minus h to h that must be equal to
minus q naught a
the minus arises because we are
uh we actually uh
we are actually considering this
positivity convention okay where the
shear
force is aligned in the same direction
as the shear stress which is pointed
downward
okay this is this pointing downward is
by the positivity convention
of the shear stress but the actual thing
uh
the actual shear force must be in the in
the upward direction
to balance this now this applied load
now will have a similar sort of
uh representation of the boundary
condition at x equal to
minus a which is the left vertical edge
so there again the total
axial force must be zero
the bending moment must be zero
and this time
the total shear force will be equal to
q naught a positive this is positive
because you note that the actual
reaction force here will also be
uh in this upward pointing direction
which coincides
with the uh with the alignment of the
positivity convention of the
shear force which in turn is aligned
with the positivity convention of the
shear stress
all right so you note how many boundary
conditions we have written down
we have 1 here we have 2 here 3 4
5 6 7 8 9
10 so quite a lot of boundary conditions
that we have to
take care of
furthermore you also note that
there will be other conditions
associated with the
choice of the air stress function and
this is where
one of the real challenges of the eddy
stress function approach is
so up to this point it is quite
deductive in nature
okay so you have been given this problem
you
arrive at this intermediate figure where
you can write down
the reaction forces like this or you can
depict the reaction forces like this
based on your undergraduate knowledge
and then from here
you can come to this mathematical
idealization but basically you are
you're borrowing or you are relying on
the same finance principle
and then from this you can write down in
a very deductive fashion
these boundary conditions but
when it comes to the question of
choosing the appropriate stress function
then it becomes a real challenge
it's a real challenge because you have
suppose
suppose we wish to write down a
polynomial type of
edit stress function now what polynomial
or what degree of the polynomial would
be appropriate here
okay so a priori we do not know we have
some idea
based on the elementary solutions that
we had looked at earlier
but we cannot say right away whether we
need
a a cubic polynomial
or a fourth degree polynomial or a fifth
degree polynomial
so what has been traditionally done
because mind you that this eddy stress
function
approach has been going on for more than
a century now
okay so in this
while or in this time many people have
tried various things and they have
almost come up
with a with a catalog of solutions
and by mixing and matching them cleverly
people
can address various problems but you
understand that
there is uh i mean in that kind of
uh approach of solving the problem or
choosing the error stress function
uh there is considerable uncertainty
there is a uh kind of uh
i mean tremendous hidden trial uh
i mean the the very way that we proceed
there is a hidden trial
kind of uh procedure
so and people have done it people have
done it and people have done it
successfully
okay uh over many many years uh
but uh given this day and age
with with the help of of the various
computer systems we have uh it is
possible to avoid that kind of
trial and error uh approach
to a considerable extent i would not say
completely avoid
but to a certain extent it can be
avoided
so what many people do
[Music]
in this modern day and age is
uh is to consider a very general area
stress function
okay so maybe hundred years ago people
did not do like that because
if you take a very general area stress
function which has
quadratic terms which has cubic terms
which has four degree terms which has
fifth degree terms
it becomes a monster okay that eddy
stress function like the corresponding
stresses
and and strains sorry the stresses the
various stress fields they become
monstrously large expressions and to
handle them
to write them on on on on paper
uh and to and to manipulate them i mean
it's a nightmare
okay so people at the very outset they
did some clever tricks
use the catalog of solutions already
available and then proceeded
but but suppose we
we rely on a computed algebra system
like
a symbolic python then
that kind of tedious algebra can be
automated
to a large extent okay
so you see
i mean i mean i hope that this kind of a
discussion
will uh will actually show you the
motivation of using
something like the jupiter notebook okay
it is not just a fanciful way of doing
it just because it is there
okay it is uh it is it is to actually
make our life easier
and to free up our brain from
unnecessary
tedious algebra okay so uh
the use of jupiter notebook can actually
help us
not only to avoid that the tedious
algebra but can also help us
to take very general kinds of eddie
stress functions
which otherwise would not be possible
which means in turn
that not only
only slight increments from the
elementary
problems can be tackled but
far more complicated problems can also
be addressed using this kind of
approach okay because we don't have to
be
uh constrained
by uh by by the limitations of what we
can do on a piece of paper
so with this i will end this lecture
and in the next one i will try to do an
implementation
of whatever i have discussed here uh
the dual degree students who are will be
listening to this will perhaps
appreciate that the kind
of of labor that will be avoided
when these boundary conditions need not
be satisfied by hand
okay and the coefficients the values of
the coefficients should not be
on by hand so with that i'll end this
lecture thank you very much